here's how to respond in one way ben
shapiro is editor-in-chief of daily
wire.com I say that was some jest in my
voice it but not really because I mean I
just had on mark pin used to work for
the Clintons this is not the Democratic
Party of old what is it well it's it's
the new Democratic Socialist Party and
this is the wave of the future according
to Tom Perez over at the DNC
what's really incredible about all of
this is that if Republicans could simply
make this referendum on democratic
extremism on the fact that this is not
even Nancy Pelosi's party anymore it's
okay Zia Cortez's party and then
Republicans would have I think a much
better shot in 2018 and going into the
future the fact is that she makes
statements that are factually untrue on
a regular basis she makes claims about
socialism that are wild and crazy she
wants to spend Bernie Sanders's plans
they they want to spend something like
218 trillion dollars over the next 30
years which would require a quadrupling
of the percentage of GDP that we spend
on government over the next thirty years
and she doesn't have to answer a single
hard question from an interviewer at any
point because she refuses to do anything
remotely resembling an interview with
somebody on the other side of the aisle
yeah and and that wouldn't be the only
reason why the tough questions might not
come I mean they have come and they've
been difficult sometimes for her she's
you know all the Middle East foreign
policy is not my thing so on and so
forth and she struggled in some areas
but quite frankly I thought her district
was here in New York and and the
Democrats are putting her out on this
main national stage and that gets
complicated no matter whom they surround
her with like Bernie Sanders whoever it
is I mean you have a direct clap back to
the soccer moms line yeah I mean the
fact is that the soccer moms aren't
driving vans anymore they're driving
SUVs and also the purpose of having a
van is that you don't have to have two
of them I'm not sure when there was ever
a soccer mom who had two vans the whole
purpose of a minivan is you can fit
everybody in one vehicle but it's also
factually untrue the fact is that the
number of mothers in American society is
actually increasing for the first time
in years over the past 10 years now
you're actually seeing an increase in
the number of women who are staying at
home I don't know why the Democrats are
now appealing to a crowd that does not
include soccer moms if they want to win
elections in the future it seems like
that should be particularly the crowd
they're aiming at you know what is it
the the passion versus the policy at a
guest on out and
over time earlier today Noel mnek poor
who put it that way and she said as long
as they stay in the passion lane that's
fine but what is the policy that goes
along
what's socialist country do we know of
where this these policies have actually
worked
that's my question yeah they they keep
shifting the answer right the USSR they
say was not socialist they say now Cuba
is not socialist in Venezuela is not
socialist now they really like the
Nordic countries which they say are
socialist ignoring of course the fact
that all wealth generated in Nordic
countries was generated by capitalism
and their social redistribution programs
have actually created massive costs for
those countries the attempt to label
what our capitalist countries with a few
socialist social systems on top of those
as socialist countries as a whole even
those countries rejected Denmark's prime
minister came to the United States a
couple of years ago when Bernie Sanders
was saying Denmark was a socialist
country and he said directly about
Bernie Sanders no we're not a socialist
country we're a capitalist country it's
easy to stand up for Marxism when you
keep shifting the explanation for why
Marxism has failed why do you think
people want to hear about democratic
socialists why do you think they're
listening to okay Zia Cortez and by the
way most Democrats say that's not my
party but generationally neither is
Nancy Pelosi Dianne Feinstein couldn't
even get an endorsement that's right I
mean I think that the reason you're
seeing people resonates this is because
the Democrats don't actually have a lot
of new ideas and anything that looks
like moderation would require them to
reach across the aisle so they're stuck
between their own Trump's arrangements
in from their hatred for the president
and the fact that they need a separate
agenda and that this creates the need
for a for an occasion cortes well Ben
Shapiro looks into it and writes about
it and is on the program tonight very
candidly thank you great to see you you
do